what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are officially picking up
with Doomsday Clock part four I know
it's been a little while since we've
covered Doomsday Clock it's being
released like bimonthly now which is
really disappointing because the story
so good and like I'm always on the edge
like like dude I really want to know
what happens next but we are on part for
it and this is the origin of like the
new Rorschach and this is kind of cool
because what this is going to do is
basically prove me wrong improve a lot
of people right I know those are those
of you guys who were part of my channel
who were just like I don't care what
happens as long as Rob is wrong so like
it's it's fine it's not a huge deal to
me it doesn really matter to me but this
is cool because this gives us like the
origin of this new version I remember
playing a little bit of catch-up for
those two guys who were you know just
now jumping into things or who have
forgotten the idea is that that Jeff
Jones is kind of blending the DC
Universe with the Watchmen universe and
we didn't know who this version of war
Shack was all we knew was that Rorschach
had just popped up inside of the
Doomsday Clock stories and of course we
knew it wasn't like the original Walter
corvax because he died at the end of
Watchmen and so in this the question
everybody had was who is this new
version of were Shaq what in the world
is going on here and so what this does
and it's a little a little confusing at
first because it actually kind of
bounces back and forth because of the
fact that this version of War Shaq had
basically appeared in the Batcave had
made his way in there and then
ultimately was you know taken by Batman
and tricked into Arkham Asylum he's
basically just been residing here ever
since but what it does is it jumps back
and forth between the past and the
present
now it's designed to be this way Geoff
Johns has been writing comic book
stories long enough that if his
intention is not to like create
bewilderment then he won't create it and
so the fact of this story is just kind
of like bouncing around and almost
leaving us with a state of confusion in
terms of what's happening in the present
was happening in the past that's
designed to be the nature of like the
Rorschach character his mind is quite
literally a wreck it's absolutely
decimated in so many different ways and
the reason for this is because what we
do is we initially pick up when he was
younger basically he's the son of
Malcolm long he's the son of the
psychologist that was analyzing Walter
Kovacs analyzing the original war shot
and picking up with him what we end up
finding out is that when his father
essentially took on the case of Walter
there were a lot of things that were
going on in the background that you know
war shacks would just call more shocked
for the sake of it there were sharks mom
was really kind of an estate like she
was struggling because her husband was
becoming more and more distant and that
was in the original Watchmen comic like
that's the way that story originally
went down is that Malcolm long became
more and more separated from his family
it became an obsession
the desire to learn about war Shack and
the desire to learn what made war shot
tick what made the original Walter
Kovacs tick that became like the drive
of of Malcolm
I'm sorry Malcolm long himself a
Reggie's dad and so because I had
eventually drove a wedge between
Reggie's mom and Reggie's father but we
didn't know the effect that it had on
Reggie and initially it didn't have a
huge one it didn't have a massive effect
on him he was just kind of watching
things that were going on and he was
sort of looking at these protests and so
on and so forth but all that changed in
the attack on New York when this monster
was unleashed in this huge psychic
backlash just swept across the city and
killed three some odd million people and
had this massive effect on him because
what it did is it drove him insane it
drove him crazy
he was one of the survivors of this
whole incident he was rescued by the
cops he was taken to an insane asylum
and that was really about it he was kind
of left there in fact he was taken to
the same institution that Mothman was
taken to you in the watchbird comics
before the Watchmen comics started and
so while the two of them were occupying
itself what we end up having is we end
up having this guy dr. Matthew Mason who
shows up and this is kind of cool
because what geoff johns does is he puts
on this kind of show bit like the cycle
repeats itself that Walter Kovacs
basically becomes a vigilante he goes
crazy he ends up getting caught ah he
ends up being thrown into an institution
and then you end up having like like
Malcolm longer shows up I'm not gonna
long interviews them and then Malcolm
long starts to become the new Rorschach
and that drives a wedge in his family
this cycle repeats itself here of course
Reggie is not married you didn't have
any children of his own but still the
the after-effects the impact of what war
shock is and what it stands for is
almost like this sort of virus that
spreads throughout things and either
Reggie himself is having like these
hallucinations he's losing his mind
he's seeing like the eye of the monster
in the forehead of Matthew Mason this is
the nature of things and that's why this
story can get a little bit confusing
because it bounces back and forth
between the past and the present but
again this is designed to tell the story
of how it was that Reggie long met
Adrian Veidt and so in his effort to
basically escape this mental institution
what he does he incapacitate one of the
guards when they show up with food or
what have you
and then takes off to the roof of the
building to try to get away and in truth
it's really one of these things of like
I just want to get away from all this
like I want to be out of here this is
not where I belong but when he gets up
there he basically ends up meeting
Mothman and Mothman statement is like
I'm flying away I'm getting out of this
place I don't need to be here I'm
perfectly sane and he literally puts on
like a moth suit we're really just kind
of like wing he's like makeshift wings
made out of bedsheets really and then
just flies away into the moon where
Reggie's basically taken by the security
guards have brought back to the
institution itself now shortly
after this this is where things get cool
shortly after this uh you end up having
Mothman who's essentially caught by the
cops would he's just outside of like
this diner and then he's brought back to
the asylum and him and Reggie begin this
sort of not really a father-son
relationship but they began like a
friendly relationship they started
talking to each other all the time now
for bio and Byron Lewis he was a really
interesting concept in the watchman's
stories I mean he came from a life of
privilege like he never really struggled
financially and for him like being a
superhero initially was more like hey
let's just go have fun it was more like
an adventurous sort of thing now that
began to change when he joined groups
like the Minuteman and then he stepped
into the role of saying well let's
actually do some good in the world
different things like that the issue is
that in the watchmen comics because the
Age of Heroes wasn't met in the same way
it was and like DC or marvel in the
sense that like superheroes were
effectively shunned not really
superheroes the people who dressed in
costumes for really kind of shunned
eventually what ended up happening is
like when the whole anti you know
superhero era came along when the whole
anti mask era came along and even during
the height of McCarthyism what you had
was Byron who basically succumb to like
alcoholism as a result of like all the
dangers and perils that went into being
a superhero and so the result was that
he was confined to a mental asylum in
Maine which seems to be where this whole
thing is going on but the idea here is
that he was always an exceedingly smart
guy and for him it was a matter of like
putting the pieces together and looking
around and seeing everything that was
going on and where he is a person that
plays the role of a friend to Reggie
what he ends up doing is he actually
manages to gather a whole bunch of
Malcolm along his belongings and bring
them to Reggie he basically gives his
son his father's things and so the
result is that Reggie starts going
through and looking at like the Journal
of war shot looking at the notes of his
father listening to the recordings all
these things and as time progresses
because of the fact that Reggie is in
such a fractured fragile mental state
what he ends up doing is actually
adopting the persona and the personality
of war shock now again this is cool
because what you have John's kind of
teases here and really what Allen wore
was sort of shooting for was that
anybody could be were shot that was the
point of the mask anybody could be
behind that mask but that's the basis
behind that's why I'm a superhero's were
perceived to be so dangerous is because
nobody knew who they were
you're a copy editor by day and like a
vigilante by night just smashing
people's heads in and breaking their
fingers and thumbs and hands like that's
that's the whole thing that went behind
that and so for Reggie like he kind of
stands with this embodiment of war shock
in the sense that at the end of the day
Walter Kovacs was just a guy who had
enough in his mind it was a matter
trying to find a way to curb the
violence so to speak you know being the
killer who kills killers if that makes
any sense
and so with regi being in that state
being you know basically like victimized
by the various authorities who were
there the orderlies inside the insane
asylum being treated like crap he just
kind of falls down tumbles down into
this path of Rorschach tumbles down into
the role of Walter Kovacs not only that
it's almost I wouldn't say Oh as far as
to say it's a little bit of manipulation
but I would go as far as to say that
when it comes to Mothman it's intriguing
because what he says is he he starts
going through and like there's just
puzzle they're working on and the puzzle
is ultimately the face of Ozymandias and
it's him basically saying if you know
how to look at this picture of the right
way then you know what's going on and
that's what happened with Reggie Reggie
just started putting all the pieces
together he looked at the Journal of
Walter corvax everything that was going
on it said like this is the fault of
Adrian Veidt it was always the falter of
Adrian Veidt initially he was kind of
trying to figure things out and trying
to work on things until he got to the
end of the journal of Walter Kovacs when
Walter Kovacs basically says like Adrian
Veidt is the reason behind all this and
that's the funny thing is because no one
else has quite figured this out yet and
the news reels there's indications
there's there's you know people who were
like speculating instinct well it seems
like it's Adrian Veidt and super you
know smart scientists and things like
that people who are trying to answer the
question of what was going on social
psychologists and what-have-you are
analysing like everything that was
taking place and saying well all the
clues seem to point to Adrian Veidt but
Reggie long is the only person that has
incontrovertible proof that Adrian Veidt
was behind it all and that's where he
full-on steps into the role of were
shocked because now what he does is he
looks around and says there's a guy out
there they killed three million people
what would war Shack have done what
would Walter Kovacs have done but Walter
Kovacs would have killed him that's what
Walter Kovacs believed needed to be done
that Adrian Veidt had to be stopped so
I'm going to pick up the slack I'm gonna
continue on this mission of Walter
Kovacs I'm going to kill Adrian Veidt
and at this point it just breaks down to
the question of how can it be done how
can it be pulled off and this is when
people begin to start realizing that
adrian veidt's the one behind all this
that's when it really began to go
topsy-turvy because remember when it
came to like the time gap between the
watchmen comics and the Doomsday Clock
comics we don't have anything to fill in
that gap all we have is what's been told
to us by Geoff Johns and like what
interviews have been done and what
speculation exists on the Internet but
by and large this answers that question
it tells us that like at the end of
Watchmen the world was united in
response to like this giant monster that
killed three million people in New York
the world was united in more
and the world looked to make the world a
better place because people began to
realize how fragile they were and then
the information came out that Adrian
Veidt was behind it all and then that
fragility shattered and the world was
worse off than it was before Veidt went
through this whole scheme of unleashing
this monster in New York you know
because people realize they've been
tricked
they'd been duped it wasn't an actual
piece and so in light of all this what
Reggie does is he actually sets a fire
inside the institution and where he and
Mothman are gonna leave and go find
Adrian instead Mothman goes back into
the building as someone just allows
himself to die and so then you have
Reggie who does takes on the whole war
shaq mantle and goes to find Adrian
Veidt who's basically on the Percy Bice
this tanker out in the middle of nowhere
but when he gets there it's intriguing
and this is where we start to get like
the reggie personality and the workshop
personality who are a little in conflict
when Reggie shows up to kill Adrian
Veidt Adrian Veidt just kind of turns
around and says look you can kill me if
you want to but like I'm dying anyway
like it's only a matter of time before I
die like there's there's nothing that
could be done I've basically got brain
cancer and it's kind of cool here
because in truth like if Adrian Veidt
were going to die anyway of what purpose
would be served by Rorschach killing him
this kind of a stance that ready takes
were shot kills people who would
otherwise be able to continue on their
normal lives just doing whatever it is
they want to do all the time but for
Adrian Veidt he's not really a criminal
he's not really a bad guy and that's the
reason why this this whole situation
works that's reason why this is so cool
one of the classic examples in a
situation like this is the trolley train
right like you're a trolley conductor
and the brakes go out on the other
brakes go out and all you have at your
control is like the steering column and
you can steer the trolley on one of two
sets of tracks on one set of tracks is
one construction worker and he's totally
oblivious has no idea this Charlie train
is just hurtling towards him is gonna
smash into him and and and kill him
entirely but if you steer it to the
other tracks there's five construction
workers you have to choose between one
or the other which one do you choose
will you choose the one construction
worker you kill that one guy in order to
save those five guys it's utilitarianism
and when you're Adrian Veidt and you're
looking around and you say humanity
there's there's seven you know seven
some odd billion people or six or five
or whatever then the absolute number
count was at the time a story was
written when you have however many
billions of people in the world who are
all going to be destroyed because the
clock is inching ever closer to nuclear
war between the US and the USSR then
like what steps do you take to unite
people people don't unite willingly
anymore it doesn't
work that way people have to be united
when there's like a massive catastrophe
what he needed was a catalyst he needed
something that would force humanity to
unite because they had to not because
they wanted to and so that's what that
monster was the monster showed up in the
city of New York it killed three million
some odd people and it was like oh my
god you know the the terrible situation
this is so awful you know in the
humanity and so on and so forth but in
light of how terrible things were and
the massive amount of casualties
humanity United and that was the goal of
Adrian Veidt what he didn't pay
attention to and what he didn't think
about was the aftermath and that's the
cool thing here is because this goes
into that whole moral philosophy like
like what what makes an act good is it
you know the consequence or is it the
act itself you know is it the intention
behind the act if adrian veidt's
intention was to unite humanity and make
the world a better place he's a good guy
if all you care about is the consequence
the world's worse off after what he did
than it was before he did what he did
then he's a bad guy he made things
terrible but that's the difference here
Adrian Veidt wasn't looking to rob
people
he wasn't looking to unleash a monster
in New York and then steal everybody's
valuables while they were all distracted
he was trying to make the world a
legitimate better place and so because
of that like you kind of have to have
pity on him and that's where he sort of
began to give up that's where he looked
around and said if humanity really
wanted to unite it would have if people
really wanted to solve the world's
problems then they would have but they
don't want to solve the world's problems
they want to goose-step themselves into
nuclear war between the US and the USSR
there's nothing that could be done
whatever happens happens and that's why
he teamed up with with Reggie long and
that's why I said we have to go find dr.
Manhattan we have to bring it back what
will happen when they do we don't know
Manhattan might show up and say well
humanity's gonna kill itself anyway so
I'll just help them all help them along
a little bit and just wipe away the
world there's any number of things that
could go on and in like the whole
Watchmen universe so because of that
what we end up doing is with the two of
them teaming up and that of course is
where Doomsday Clock number one picks up
we jump back to the modern day here in
issue number four after Reggie had been
thrown into Arkham Asylum by Bruce Wayne
and so one is um happening here is
basically he has a conversation with
what appears to be Saturn the girl from
the Legion of super-heroes because she's
been locked up in Arkham Asylum the
entire time that's where she's been this
whole time that was teased back in DC
Universe rebirth number one and so what
she says is like we have to get out of
here like we have to make our escape
she's already out like she's literally
out of herself and just roaming around
and she's like we have to get out of
here you know because I don't have that
much
hunt and whatever's coming is gonna
require like the entire superhero
community if we don't work together
we're all going to not and that's what's
cool because it's basically saying like
dr. Manhattan is coming here it's only a
matter of time before he does and so the
two of them basically team up and who
knows what happens out there you know
out to find out the next issue what we
also end up finding out and this is a
cool indication here what seems to have
happened is that dr. matthew mason was a
fictional person he didn't exist instead
it looks it looks like it was Alfred
Pennyworth although I still think it's
Batman but it looks like it was Alfred
Pennyworth who was disguised as Matthew
Mason who went walking into the insane
asylum pretending to be a psychologist
trying to understand who were shocked is
and that makes sense
Batman's not gonna take that person
throw him into Arkham Asylum and then
just throw away the key and never ever
ask any questions that it doesn't work
like that it's always the significance
of gathering information finding out as
much as he can as often as you can
and that's exactly what's been going on
here they've basically been
investigating Reggie long without him
knowing it and so that's where the
question becomes will Batman side with
Reggie or will Batman stand against
Reggie but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come as explained
and make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the raw pork
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
peace
you
[Music]